-There are 10 types of
people in the world.
Those who understand binary,
and those who don't.
MATT PARKER: OK, it doesn't
really work when it's said.
But written down, the
joke kind of holds.
Because if I do a 1 and
then a 0, that looks
like the number 10.
Because you expect it to be
a normal base 10 number.
However, if this is in binary,
then this is our units column.
That's our twos column.
And so this actually equals
2 in base 10.
And so you expect it to
be 10, but it's not.
It's 2, and that's the joke.
There are actually two
types of people.
Those who knew this was binary,
and those who didn't.
-There are 10 types of
people in the world.
Those who understand binary,
those who don't, and those who
didn't expect this joke
to be in base 3.
MATT PARKER: OK, good point,
because I guess you--
OK, so it depends on the base.
So if you've got 10, but this
time it's in base 3, then now
you've got a units column, and
then a threes column, and then
nines, and so on.
And so that in normal numbers
would be 3 in base 10.
And so the same 1 and 0 in
a different base mean 3.
Hence the three categories.
-There are 10 types of
people in the world.
Those who understand binary,
those who don't, and--
MATT PARKER: Look, you can
generalize it to any base, OK?
10 in base b is going to
equal b in base 10, OK?
There's an infinite set
of these jokes.
Cut it out.
-There are 10 types of
people in the world.
Those who understand
hexadecimal, and F the rest.
MATT PARKER: OK, I give it to
you, that one is actually
quite funny.
Because now in hexadecimal,
which is base 16--
10 in base 16 still does mean
there are 16 types of people.
And so there's the one category
of people who
understand hexadecimal,
base 16.
But then the remaining
15 in hexadecimal--
15 is just the letter F. And so
when they say F the rest,
they're saying 15
are the rest.
Or I guess the joke is the
double meaning, where if you
just say F in a sentence, it
means you're implying--
uh, fools.
You're saying they're very
foolish, all the people who
don't understand hexadecimal.
-Why do mathematicians confuse
Halloween and Christmas?
Because Oct 31 equals Dec 25.
MATT PARKER: OK, so the
joke here is that Oct
31 equals Dec 25.
And the surface reading is that
this stands for October,
and this stands for December.
But it doesn't.
Oct can stand for the eighth
thing, because October is the
eighth month in the--
it was until Julius Caesar
messed with it.
And Dec used to be the 10th
month, blah, blah, blah.
So anyway, instead of using
these as months, you can use
Oct to mean base 8.
So instead of 31 being in our
normal base 10 setup, if we
put it into base 8, you
have a units column.
You have an eights column.
And so you've now got one
unit and three 8's.
And three 8's is 24, plus
a single unit equals 25.
And so 31 in base 8 equals 25
in base 10, which is why one
equals the other, and
why a mathematician
would confuse them.
BRADY HARAN: This video was
supported by audible.com.
And if you'd like to download
one of their 100,000 titles
for free, go to
audible.com/numberphile.
I actually sampled the product
myself in the last few weeks.
I downloaded a couple of
mountaineering books while I
was holidaying in Nepal.
I love books about mountains.
These are the two I chose.
They were both excellent.
And it was actually really good
fun to be walking through
the mountains while listening to
the book, having it sort of
inside my head.
So I recommend those two as
possible ones when you
download your free one.
That's audible.com/numberphile,
and
thanks to them for supporting
our videos.
[LAUGHTER]